Kiribati Mahalo says everything is
getting increasingly expensive in South
Africa and even basic goods are now a
luxury she has never had a job and has
two boys to feed clothe and sent to
school all of them sleep in this
one-room shack on the same bed sometimes
I don't have money to buy any food and
now the this boots open I don't have buy
the kids for a uniform you know more
than 25 years since apartheid ended in
South Africa government's affirmative
action plans and black economic
empowerment policies have failed to stop
growing inequality and poverty
now some politicians are proposing land
the mines and the country's central bank
be nationalized unlike most central
banks in the world Africa is privately
owned the ruling African National
Congress insist nationalized in the bag
is the only way to ensure wealth is
redistributed more fairly natural
ization is a sensitive topic in South
Africa
some people feel nationalized in the
Central Bank will scare away investors
and further weaken the country's already
struggling economy what nationalization
would allow the ANC to do is to print
money effectively and cause a
hyperinflation of the kind that we've
seen in Zimbabwe of the kind that we saw
between the wars in the biome our
republic and various other european
countries that we've seen across history
and the reasons that they might want to
do that or that the current the country
is basically running out of money
at the moment some state-owned companies
essential to the economy are in trouble
South African Airways is in financial
crisis and has had to suspend some
domestic and international flights and
power company is calm is thirty billion
dollars in debt and struggling to
maintain electricity supplies mining
companies are warning that crisis could
push the country into a recession we
need to be fair here not everything in
this country's dysfunctional and we can
pinpoint to the reasons why this is
personal things have actually imploded
in collapsed we have about a problem of
corruption we do have that and the only
way to deal with corruption is not to
say that the state should never own
anything to sort out corruption
corruption is not a South African
phenomena it's a phenomenon presidents
or Ramapo stays under pressure to revive
investor competence and boost economic
growth but he has to balance two sides
those who favor encouraging the growth
of private businesses and many
politicians in the ruling ANC party who
are calling for more black economic
empowerment policies including taking
land for redistribution without
compensating the owners her Matassa al
jazeera Johannesburg